fans of that 70s show probably noticed
the show's plot start to unravel in the
second half of the series for example
some may have noticed the years on the
license plates becoming consistent
around season four the first three
seasons display a new year starting in
1977
after the fourth season the years all
stayed the same suggesting four seasons
passing in a single year compared to the
previous four seasons in four years
perhaps the writers made the mistake of
starting a sitcom based in the 70s a
little too late in the decade and were
forced to remain in a single year for
continuity reasons however super fans
may remember there being a christmas
episode every season yet all of those
christmases would have had to occur in a
single year once fans started to think
about some of the plot holes in the
later seasons they may have wondered if
everything they saw on the show was true
or if something else was going on that
fans weren't aware of some fans have
taken this to the next level proposing a
theory that might make a little too much
sense let's check out the eric theory
that changes everything on that 70s show
in season 4 episode 15 tornado prom eric
foreman goes to prom with his group of
stoner friends but he forgets to bring
his girlfriend donna who is stuck at the
radio station where she works
this is a classic form and blunder that
we've come to expect from eric being the
lovable character he is he decides to
rescue his stranded lady while doing so
a tornado is seen behind eric's car but
he doesn't notice it the episode goes on
as usual and the two are reunited they
make it to prom and everything seems
great at least on the surface some fans
especially at entertainment weekly took
a deeper look at that episode and came
up with a fan theory that would change
everything about the show if you
remember while the prom is going on the
parents of eric and donna are watching
the news regarding the tornado when they
hear
this just in the national weather
service has canceled the tornado warning
and updating our top story a local teen
is in critical religion you need a good
ear to hear it but the theory goes that
eric foreman never actually made it to
donna instead the tornado caught up to
eric who is the local teen in critical
condition as a result eric falls into a
coma this would explain many of the
inconsistencies throughout the second
half of the show let's say this was true
how would this have affected the rest of
the show the theory is that since eric
is in a coma and not dead the show
continues based on his memory and how he
believes certain situations would unfold
for example a few seasons later eric
decides to move to africa to become a
teacher this is a little out of
character for eric but it also could
mean that eric was falling deeper into
his coma this could be something eric
always wanted to do but couldn't because
he'd always been stuck in wisconsin
following that eric is replaced by new
character randy who could be seen as
eric's imagined version of his older
self it could also mean he is falling
even deeper into his coma and losing
perspective on what is plausible this
idea is bolstered even further when fez
marries jackie and laurie on two
separate occasions another example of
fuzzy logic in later episodes is when
eric's mom kitty begins to record
everything that eric is missing this is
potentially a way for eric to stay
connected with what's going on at home
while he is in the coma none of this
makes sense in the surface level plot
but eric doesn't know that because he is
drifting further and further away from
reality in the series finale everyone is
waiting for eric to return from africa
on new year's eve he does so in the last
few minutes of the show and a
warm-hearted reunion at a familiar spot
concludes the series i wish there was
just some way to take the edge off
edge
you were officially off of course fans
weren't satisfied with this and had to
work this event into their theory let's
assume eric was supposed to make a
recovery on december 31 1979 when the
show was supposed to end the theory
suggests that eric doesn't make it back
home that he is still in a coma and that
this is his last goodbye to everyone his
memory allows for one last time to
remember all of his friends and family
back home then when the series ends that
is when eric allegedly dies
it's a dark theory but when you think
about it it could make sense in the end
it's undeniable that there are several
plot holes in the later seasons and
maybe this could be explained by
something like the main character being
struck by a tornado and falling into a
coma for a year or maybe the riders just
lost the plot perhaps we'll never know
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]